hello everybody I hope that you are good
this is a quick Bitcoin update so far
what I can see is that we are above the
daily 50 EMA so for now we are safe
though remember that if we break below
the 50 EMA in the daily time frame then
we are going to see Bitcoin rolling over
even more and the next Target would be
25 200 but for now we're above it so we
are safe now if you go to the owner time
frame there was a very interesting move
that happened last night in my case and
it was the Bitcoin to hit exactly 28 000
round number not pennies which is quite
interesting that's a footprint of the
market maker um what I can see here
is that this candle left a week around
the market for you
I would say that it's around
this this area here
27 900 so that week in principle should
be failed
okay but then we also have another story
we're gonna go to High Block in a moment
to check all these liquidations but I've
noticed that here if you go to the left
in the chart from 28th of March we have
a liquidity pool okay let me market for
use this one
that hasn't been retraced yet so let me
extend this box for you
okay
all the way here and you can see that
hasn't been retraced yet so Bitcoin
might come to this level still okay now
if you remember we were going to
Havelock capital in a moment but in
yesterday's video we saw a liquidation
soon in the 27 000 and the 26900 and
this pretty much matches with those
liquidation so why not why couldn't we
see something like this for today
okay
that's understandable I'm gonna keep an
eye on of course if it goes low and then
the daily candle close closes below the
value 50 EMA then I'm not going too long
I'm going to be favorite in shorts but
if it goes low retraces this liquidity
pool and hit all those liquidations and
then it bounces hard to fill this week
and it closes above the daily 50 EMA
then we are good and between could go
higher obviously take this with a pinch
of salt because the New York session
hasn't even started yet he starts from
in two hours from here so this is still
time for any kind of surprise and also
as I told you yesterday this week is
going to be quite a difficult week for
trade and that's what I'm anticipating
so let's trade level by level let's see
what the market gives us and then let's
execute any trades with that
if you go to High block Capital let's
see what we find in the liquidation
street map this is the 12 hours I
usually don't pay attention to this
chart I'm gonna be honest with you but
it's interesting when we see a yellow
bar like this because then usually it
goes there you can see in this case
there was a yellow butter 27 300 when we
were at 27 500 and then price went there
and then bounced and now we can see that
there is another Jello bar at 27
875 which if you remember from the
previous chart I just showed you that's
the 50 of the week so there is a bit of
Confluence there okay so let's go now to
the one month time frame I checked the
seven days already that is not really
much going on there but in the one month
time frame
this is what I sold yesterday too there
is still quite a lot of liquidity at 27
000 and 26 900 which which also matches
with that liquidity pool we marked okay
that's soon that has to still be
retraced so we've seen that we have some
Confluence with the liquidations at the
50 of the week with the 12 hour time
frame liquidations hit them up and also
at the liquidation pool that we marked
at twenty seven thousand and twenty six
thousand and hundred that also matches
with the one month time frame
liquidations
so now let me ask you this question what
do you think happens first
retrace the liquidity pool and then fill
the week
or fill the wig and then retrace that
liquidity pool to the downside that
question is what I have in my head today
okay I'm leaning more or this is what I
would prefer to see is to First retrace
the liquidity pool and then fill the
wick
and close the daily candle above the
daily 50 EMA because then I could favor
longs
okay
Bo if we first fail the week and then we
go to register liquidity pool and we
close the daily Candlestick below the
fifth EMA then I'll be favored in shorts
It's that simple it's a game of
probabilities and sometimes you just
have to wait to see what the market
gives you we can say that right now what
is still within the weekend range let's
go there let's see Saturday
okay let's see what the range is today
here
and well it's Sunday already closed the
weekend around here
okay so you can see that we extend this
this was the weekend range if we extend
this
what is still within the weekend range
so this is a zone of choppiness so guys
I like that word choppiness so guys be
careful here you know
wait to see what the market gives you
if it fills the week then maybe you
could aim for the liquidity pool to get
retrace and if it fails the liquidity
pool and then switch the lows then maybe
you could be looking for the week to be
filled obviously there's no Financial
advice but whatever you decide to do
today just remember to be careful apply
risk management stop losses in place
because you know the same as I was
anticipating last week to be a very good
week for trading and it was now
anticipating to be quite choppy quick
for trading so guys be careful all I'm
gonna wait is a deviation out of this
range out of this box if price today you
know do something like this
I'm not gonna trade is because you know
there is no much to trade in this box
I'm waiting for a deviation
it's also very important to get to know
your own trading assistant you don't
trade in a style
mine is explained in the course there is
a link in the to the website in the
description
and I know that based on my trading
system what I'm going to be favoring is
high probability trade so I know that
here the 50 of the range there is not
gonna be any high probability trade for
me
so that's what I'm gonna wait for the
deviation let's see what the market
gives me is it going to fill it with
first or retrace the liquidity pool
first and then I will play accordingly
but anyway guys that's pretty much
everything thank you so much for
watching
and I'll see you soon